Seventh Day Adventism, is this a cult or a true
Christian church? I'm going to answer that in
a moment. You're going to hear about their
history. You're going to also learn about what
they believe. Some of the beliefs that are very
consistent with Orthodox Christian Evangelical
beliefs as well as some beliefs that are very
sketch. Now the seventh day Adventists are known
for the doctrine that is in their name, keeping
the Sabbath. Some know Seventh Day Adventists as
health conscious and frequently vegetarian. Some
even know about a woman named Ellen White whose
writings, the SDA which is short for Seventh
Day Adventist church treats as virtually Holy
Scripture. However, the real distinctive doctrine
of SDA church, the doctrine that really drives
all other beliefs is called the investigative
judgment. Now we will look carefully at this
doctrine but first let's learn some statistics and
some history. The Seventh Day Adventist church has
95,297 churches with almost 22 million
members. And 20,924 ordained ministers
across 212 countries. Now the SDA church
operates 9,419 schools including primary,
secondary and university levels. 229 hospitals,
57 publishing houses and branches. The famous
people that are associated with SDA church include
musicians like Prince, Little Richard, basketball
player Magic Johnson, politician Ben Carlson and
Malcolm X who initially attended SDA services
before he converted to Islam. Now the Seventh Day
Adventist church emerged from the Second Great
Awakening 1795 to 1835. It was a period of intense
religious revival in America. During this time,
a Baptist preacher William Miller studied Bible
prophecy for 13 years and he predicted that Jesus
would return in 1844. I'm not sure if he read
the verse where the Bible says nobody knows the
day but he made a prediction that in 1844, Jesus
will come. He began preaching this second advent
message in 1831, drawing between 50,000 to 100,000
followers. Some actually estimate that he was was
reaching up to a million people. Now of course, on
October 22, 1844 Jesus did not come which led to
the great disappointment. That is the terminology
that's used in SDA church which deeply distressed
Miller's followers. The next day after this great
disappointment when Jesus didn't come, Hiram Edson
had a vision of Jesus entering the heavenly
sanctuary to begin a special work of judgment,
leading to the belief that the date was correct
but the event was misunderstood. Now, here's the
quote from Midnight Cry that explains Hiram's
vision that he had and I quote, We started, and
while passing through a large field I was stopped
about midway of the field. Heaven seemed opened
to my view, and I saw distinctly and clearly that
instead of our High Priest coming out of the Most
Holy of the heavenly sanctuary to come to this
earth on the tenth day of the seventh month,
at the end of the 2300 days, He for the first
time entered on that day the second apartment
of that sanctuary; and that He had a work to
perform in the Most Holy Place before coming to
the earth. Now this Hiram Edson developed the
teaching of the investigative judgment which
became the key belief of the SDA church. Another
figure in the SDA church is Ellen White. She had
over 2,000 visions starting at the age of 17,
providing hope and guidance to the SDA church.
After the great disappointment, she promoted
observing the Sabbath on the seventh day. She
wrote extensively producing over 100,000 pages of
text and advocating a vegetarian diet emphasizing
that fruits, grains, vegetables and dairy as the
most helpful foods. Here is a short timeline of
SDA history. In 1844 was the great disappointment.
In 1851 Ellen White publishes her first book,
a sketch of the Christian experience and views
of Ellen G White. In 1863 the 7th Day Adventist
church was founded in Battle Creek, Michigan with
3,500 members. In 1901 SDA church has a membership
of 75,000 people. In 1940 SDA membership exceeds
half a million. In 1955 SDA membership surpasses 1
million and as of 2022 the membership is about 22
million. Here are six doctrines where Evangelical
doctrine and SDA doctrine are the same. The
first one is Trinity. There's no problems there.
Although Ellen White had some issues in this
area, the current SDA church is Trinitarian,
believing in the Father, Son and the Holy
Spirit. The second doctrine is that the Bible
is scripture. That is the same as Evangelical
Christianity but SDA deviates in adding other
writing so they're not really Sola scriptura even
though though they claim to be on their official
website. The third doctrine that we agree with
is doctrine about Jesus. They believe that Jesus
is fully God and fully man that He was born of a
virgin and He lived a sinless life and He died for
the sins of humanity and was raised from the dead.
The fourth doctrine where there is agreement is
that Jesus is coming back to earth. The Savior's
coming will be literal, personal, visible and
worldwide. When He returns, the righteous
dead will be resurrected and together with
the righteous living will be glorified and taken
to heaven but the unrighteous will die, basically
in line with the Evangelical Christianity.
Evangelicals hold various views on end times
but the basis on which we agree is very similar to
what SDA believes. The fifth one is the new earth
but here God Himself will dwell with His people
and suffering and death will be passed away. So
basically same doctrine as evangelicals. The sixth
one is the water baptism and the Lord's supper.
SDA churches practice both ordinances which are
standard within Evangelical Christianity. Now,
the rest of this video I'm going to focus on the
five doctrines that are different from Evangelical
Christianity. The first one is the prophetic
ministry of Ellen G White. SGA church believes
that the scripture testify that one of the gifts
of the Holy Spirit is prophecy and that this gift
is an identifying mark of the remnant church
and they believe that it was manifested in the
ministry of Ellen G White. Her writings speak with
prophetic authority and provide comfort, guidance,
instruction and correction to the church.
They also make it clear that the Bible is
the standard by which all teaching and experience
must be tested but this is a major problem because
SDA puts this Ellen White's writings on the par
with the Bible. Evangelical Christians even and
especially Pentecostal Charismatic churches reject
putting any prophecy on the same level as the
Bible. The second doctrine and that is keeping
the law as found in the ten commandments. SDA
believes that the basis of God's covenant with
His people is the ten commandments highlighted
by the Holy Spirit to reveal sin and the need for
a Savior. Salvation is by grace not by works and
it results in obedience to the ten commandments.
Now Evangelical Christians however believe that
Christians fulfill the law through Christ living
within them not by legalistic adherence. They
point to the fact that Jesus rose on Sunday
which they refer to as the Lord's day and
that early Christians met on Sundays for worship
and fellowship. Acts 20:7 and 1 Corinthians 16:2.
We believe that Paul taught against observing
special days including the Sabbath. Colossians
chapter 2:16 and 17. Now Seventh Day Adventist
emphasize Sabbath keeping, asserting that it
was mandated by the fourth commandment and was
the original practice of the Jerusalem church.
Now they argue that Constantine changed the day of
worship to Sunday in 321 AD. However, Evangelicals
note that Paul opposed Judaizers who insisted on
Jewish customs like Sabbath keeping and wrote the
book of Galatians against such practices. In fact,
Paul stated that following the law including the
circumcision and Sabbath keeping was a return to
slavery and contrary to the freedom in Christ.
Read Galatians chapter 5:1-4. Early Christians
like Justin Martyr also indicated that they did
not observe the Sabbath as Jews did, supporting
Evangelical stance. Third doctrine where there is
disagreement, cessation of existence at physical
death. SDA church believes that the wages of sin
is death but God who alone is immortal will grant
eternal life to His redeemed. Until that day,
death is an unconscious state for all
people. When Christ who is our life appears,
the resurrected righteous and the living righteous
will be glorified and caught up to meet the Lord.
The second resurrection, the resurrection of the
unrighteous will take place after 1,000 years.
Now this is not a Christian doctrine because Paul
taught that to be absent from the body is to be
present with the Lord 2 Corinthians 5:8. Paul did
not indicate that when we die, we go into a soul
unconscious sleep, we go straight to be
with Jesus. The fourth doctrine where
there is disagreement is no earthly millennium.
According to the Seventh Day Adventist church,
the millennium is 1,000 year reign of Christ
with His saints in heaven between the first and
the second resurrections. During this time,
the wicked man will be judged and the earth
will be utterly desolate without living
human inhabitants but occupied by Satan
and his angels. At its close, Christ with
His saints and the holy city will descend
from heaven on earth. The unrighteous dead
will then be resurrected and with Satan and
his angels will surround the city but fire from
God will consume them and cleanse the earth. Thus
the universe will be freed from sin and sinners
forever. The book of Revelations teaches us that
the millennial reign of Jesus will be physical on
the planet earth not in heaven. The fifth doctrine
where there is sharp disagreement and this is
a big doctrine and that is the investigative
judgment. As I mentioned earlier where that was
birthed, when one guy missed the date of when
Jesus was supposed to come back which he should
have not been playing with those dates in the
first place because the Bible is very clear. We
don't know when Jesus is coming. We can see the
signs but we don't know exact date. So anyway
so to kind of cover that great disappointment
you know they had a vision that Jesus is pretty
much doing an investigative judgment since that
day. It's a key SDA believe in investigative
judgment where they believe that they will
be judged based on their obedience to God's
commandments especially Sabbath keeping. This
judgment which begun in 1844 evaluates the lives
of all believers starting with the Old Testament
saints and continuing until the present. SDA's
believe that until this investigation is complete,
individuals are not fully saved. So this is what
Ellen White, a key figure in SDA theology wrote,
When sin has been repented of, confessed and
forsaken then pardon is written against the
sinner's name but I want you to listen to this
but his sins are not blotted out until after the
investigative judgment. She also emphasized that
believers should never claim that they are saved,
stating that those who accept the Savior, however
sincere their conversion should never be taught
to say or to feel that they are saved as long
as a man is full of weakness for of himself,
he cannot save his soul. He should never dare to
say, I am saved. Well, hold on Ellen White, you
are off here. This whole investigative judgment is
just not biblical. What does the Bible say about
investigative judgment? Well, the Bible says that
God already knows those who are His. John 10:14,
2 Timothy 2:19. Our sins are blotted out when we
believe on Jesus and when we walk in repentance,
confessing, fellowship with Him. Acts 3:19,
1 John 1:7-9. The atonement was finished on
the cross. John 19:30, Hebrews 10:12-14, Romans
5:1- 2 and Romans 5:8-1. Ellen White and SDA do
not understand salvation. It is true that we
must be faithful to the end to be saved but
we're also saved in the present. Jesus saved us
when we believed on Him. We are presently saved.
We will on the day gain our new heavenly bodies
and be immortal like Jesus. We will experience
the final salvation however you can know right now
that you are saved. That's the basis of Christian
faith. Ephesians 2:8-10 say, For by the grace you
have been saved, not you have to wait for some
investigation to be finished. No by the grace, you
have been saved. That's past tense, through faith
and that is not of yourselves. It is the gift of
God not of works so that no man can boast. For we
are His workmanship created in Christ Jesus for
good works which God prepared beforehand so we
should walk in them. Notice it says, you have
been saved. Our salvation is a present reality
but what about judgment? Well, the Bible does talk
about judgment in Daniel chapter 7, Revelation 20,
Matthew 12 says that we will be judged for every
idol work that was spoken. However in John 5:24
it says, we will not come into judgment for our
past sins. It says this, Truly truly I say to you,
he who hears My word and believes Him who sent Me
has eternal life and does not come into judgment
but has passed out of death into life. If we walk
in sin, yes, we will be judged. If we walk in the
light, the blood of Jesus cleanses us from all
sin. 1 John 1:7. So then do believers experience
judgment? Not for our past sins but we will
be judged by Jesus Christ. It's called the
judgment seat of Christ where our ministry will be
judged. 1 Corinthians 3:10-15. Our interpersonal
relationships will be judged. Ephesians 6:9 and
Colossians 4:1. Our devotion to Christ will be
judged. Revelation chapters 2 and chapters 3. But
these things they don't determine our salvation,
they determine our reward. Should Christians feel
uncertainty about their standing with God? Never.
We must know that the gospel assures us of
salvation. We must also examine our lives that
we are living in line with the gospel. We can know
that we are saved. We can know that we are right
with God. We never need to live in uncertainty
or fear. So this pretty much recaps the Seventh
Day Adventist church doctrines we agree with and
doctrines we disagree with. Now I don't consider
Seventh Day Adventists as a non-Christian cult
like Jehovah's Witnesses or Mormons. From 1840
to 1950, many evangelicals believed that the
Seventh Day Adventists were a non-Christian
cult like Jehovah's Witnesses and Mormons but
after the dialogue with the SDA scholars and
apologist swhich happened in 1950s, this led a
lot of the Evangelical community to reconsider
how they view Seventh Day Adventists to view them
as a denomination that has moved from accepted
doctrine. A person can be a Seventh Day Adventist
and still be a born again believer at the same
time. There is enough potential risk to warn us
against joining a Seventh Day Adventist church.
I would strongly encourage believers not to
get involved in Seventh Day Adventism. Why?
Because they are embracing the same as those
Jews in the book of Galatians and Paul used
very strong language and he said that if they want
to circumcise then he hoped that they would go all
the way and just cut off their organs completely.
I mean Paul used a very strong language. So we as
gentile believers you know we are saved by grace.
We're not saved by keeping the law of Moses and
when we are saved, we're not saved so we can keep
the law of Moses. We are saved so we can keep the
commandments and the words of Jesus Christ. Thank
you for watching this video. I hope that you found
this to be encouraging, enlightening, instructing
and convicting. If you are a Seventh Day
Adventist, I love you, appreciate you watching.
Let me know your thoughts. Is there some things
that I mentioned that were not right? If you are
a Seventh Day Adventist, I would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below. Maybe you used
to be a Seventh Day Adventist, would love to
hear your experience as well. Don't forget to hit
like, subscribe and share this video with others.